liebe männer wenn ihr wissen wollt wir
frauen auf jeden fall herum kriegt habe
ich jetzt die antwort für euch lasst die
musik hören ein experiment aus wien
zeigt nämlich jetzt dass frauen männer
sehr viel attraktiver finden wenn sie
musik hören und zwar die richtige wie
genau musik die sexuelle anziehung
beeinflusst welche musik ihr beim dayton
unbedingt spielen müsst und ob das
gleiche auch für frauen gilt jetzt in
klicks um science-fiction herzlich
willkommen
man müsste klavier spielen können ja an
diesen uralten lied von johannes
heesters scheint sogar wissenschaftlich
etwas dran zu sein in der forschung
unumstritten ist die wirkung die musik
auf uns hat schon embryos im bauch der
mutter reagieren auf musik sie steckt
einfach tief in unserer natur darin
übrigens hat sich schon charles darwin
mit der wirkung der musik
auseinandergesetzt seiner meinung nach
hat sie sich überhaupt erst durch die
sexuelle selektion entwickelt demnach
hatten diejenigen personen den größten
fort fand forschungserfolg die die
fähigkeit besaßen musik zu machen denn
das galt seiner meinung nach als
indikator für gute gene
fest steht jedenfalls musik ist sehr eng
mit der menschlichen gefühlswelt
verknüpft und nicht nur das frühere
studien haben gezeigt dass musik nicht
nur unseren geist berührt sondern auch
unseren körper
wir nehmen berührung tatsächlich anders
war
wenn wir während dessen musik hören und
nicht nur das auch die aktivität unserer
gene verändert sich ein experiment aus
wien zeigt jetzt dass musik auch bei der
partnerwahl eine enorm große rolle
spielen kann
zitat die attraktivität des gesichts ist
eines der wichtigsten körperlichen
merkmale welches die partnerwahl
beeinflussen kann
wir wollten herausfinden wie musik die
wahrnehmung dieses merkmals womöglich
verändert sagt der beteiligte psychologe
helmut leder insgesamt 690 versuchs
teilnehmerinnen und teilnehmer waren am
experiment der uni wien beteiligt den
ausschließlich heterosexuellen probanden
wurden musik ausschnitte vorgespielt und
links rein instrumentale musik aus dem
19 jahrhundert so etwas wie brahms
chopin oder schubert danach wurden in
fotos von menschen mit den jeweils
anderen geschlecht gezeigt die leute auf
den bildern
zeigten einen neutralen gesichtsausdruck
die aufgabe bestand darin die menschen
auf den fotos hinsichtlich ihrer
attraktivität zu beurteilen zudem
sollten sie sagen ob sie einem date
zustimmen würden die kontrollgruppe sei
auch gesichter allerdings ohne musik und
das ergebnis ist wirklich mehr als
überraschend die frauen ließen sich in
ihrer beurteilung total von der musik
beeinflussen wenn sie zuvor musik gehört
hatten fanden sie die gesichter der
männer deutlich attraktiver zudem waren
sie deutlich öfter bereit ein date mit
diesen männern zu haben
liebe männer hiermit also der offizielle
tipp von seiten der wissenschaft
organisiert euch für eure days music das
erhöht eure chancen enorm wichtig dazu
noch zu wissen auch die art der musik
spielt eine große rolle
das experiment aus wien zeigt dass
frauen sich sexuell umso mehr von
männern angezogen fühlen je komplexer
und erregender die zuvor gehörte musik
war so die studie die männer dagegen
waren total unbeeindruckt von der musik
sie zeigten sich völlig immun gegen die
wirkung der musik der plan des
forschungsteams ist jetzt herauszufinden
inwieweit das musikalische talent eine
rolle bei der partnerwahl spielt hat ein
herausragender musiker der mittelmäßig
aussieht eventuell mehr chancen bei den
frauen als ein völlig unmusikalische man
mit dem aussehen eines models also nach
dem motto man müsste klavier spielen
können ja hier bei pixum erfahrt ihr
natürlich wenn es halt so neue
erkenntnisse gibt wenn er kein video zum
thema und auch zu allen anderen themen
verpassen wollt dann würden wir hier ein
abo aufsaugen vergessen ich den auf die
glocke hier geht es weiter mit bedroht
künstliche intelligenz die menschheit da
geht es um den sieg von alpha go
spannendes video natürlich also nicht
verpassen und draufklicken viel spaß
dabei und ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran